wir haben jetzt 7 Monate Krieg ähm und
wir haben vor 7 Monaten gewusst was
unsere Achillesferse ist deswegen
Energieversorgung Energie ist Leben
Energie ist Wohlstand und auch eine Zahl
zu nennen soll nicht so viele Zahlen
nennen aber vor dem Krieg hat die
Europäische Union ein Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes der jährlichen
Wirtschaftsleistung ausgegeben für
Energie jetzt sind es 5 %. was heißt die
Kosten explodiert und was wir jetzt
erleben ist eigentlich die Gefahr einer
vor allem nicht nur schleichen
stattfinden sagt gut stattfindet die
Industrialisierung in Deutschland wir
verlieren Wohlstand weil wir haben
natürlich wieder hier schon gespart
wurde gesagt das gespart nur die
Wahrheit ist da wurden die einfach
gespart da ist auf Produktion jetzt
schon stillgelegt worden da sollte man
sich die Philos ein schlechtes Zeichen
und ich werfe der Regierung eigentlich
vor dass sie nicht gehandelt hat das war
vor sieben Monaten klar was passiert das
heißt man hätte alles tun müssen die
energieversorge in Deutschland
auszuweiten alle Kohlekraftwerke die
funktionsfähig sind anmachen alle
Atomkraftwerke nicht nur weil
überlaufzeit über ein paar Wochen
diskutieren sondern über gleich sagen
wir stellen die Brennstäbe es Angebot
lag auf dem Tisch von westing aus wir
hätten die Brennstäbe wahrscheinlich
jetzt diesen Dezember schon bekommen wir
hätten 6 Atomkraftwerk gelaufen lassen
können das wäre ungefähr 15 Prozent der
deutschen Strombedarfs wir hätten
darüber hinaus ganz schnell anfangen
müssen sagen der Fall feuern kein Gas
mehr für die Stromerzeugung so teuer
macht all das wurde nicht gemacht und
deshalb bin ich ganz andere Auffassung
die Bundesregierung hat sieben Monate
über Krieg geredet überall die große
Sache geredet was er das machen würde
und hat die Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht
und der Preis den wir zahlen ist ein
bitterer es geht ja nicht darum zu sagen
ich verhindern ein Blackout natürlich
soll man das verhindern es geht nicht
darum dass er eine gasmangelage
verhindert übrigens verhindern es geht
darum dass wir die Affe achtfachen der
Energiepreise haben für die Wirtschaft
und das hält die nicht aus und letztes
Beispiel noch dazu als Corona war hat
man gesagt na gut wir schließen das
Restaurant das ist jetzt schade und es
macht ein paar wollten später wieder auf
ist ja habe herrnberg Modell haben heute
nicht da und dann geht wieder als weiter
er hatte funktioniert und es nicht
funktioniert hat da war es ein anderer
Wörter aufgemacht hat in der Industrie
ist das anders wenn Fabrikation hier zu
sind darf man nicht davon gehen dass Sie
ein paar Jahren wieder aufmachen werden
hier das heißt wir brauchen eine
Strategie über die energieangebote
massiv erhöhen und da muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen da ist die Bundesregierung
in weiten Teilen Entschuldigung
eigentlich verloren auch wenn ich gerade
in die Kommunikation Atomkraftwerk das
wieder heute gehört hat denke und zum
zweiten hat sie auch keine Antwort
gefunden wie sie die Firmen Schutz vor
dem Gast ein Beispiel geben wir haben in
Deutschland gastvorräte die
entsprechenden Lieferung aus Russland
von 40 Jahren wir fördern ihn nicht aus
Umweltgründen als wäre es
umweltschonender in USA Fracking zu
betreiben und hierher zu transportieren
auf Schiffen es ist völliger Irrsinn wir
sagen wir sollten hier und übrigens es
hätte ungefähr sechs Monate gedauert bis
erste Gas geflossen wäre wir müssen
Flecken hier betreiben
selbstverständlich und das ist auch
immer eine Geschichte es ist
umweltschädlich schwierig ist das kann
man alles machen in Deutschland wird
würde es beherrscht Technologie und das
wäre eigentlich die Frage wo ich sage
das ist übrigens wo ich darauf fasse und
bin dass der Krieg viel früher begann
hat nämlich die Frage ist warum
entscheiden wir so viele Dinge zu tun
warum es vielleicht in so verpönt die
britische Regierung hat freding verboten
Informationen das auch Russland bereits
schon die letzten Jahren Jahrzehnten
eigentlich schon Aktivitäten
Unterstützer die gesagt haben wir machen
kein Fracking wir machen kein Atomkraft
und so weiter und so fort und das ist
das Ergebnis der ganzen Sache nur wir
sind ein Wirtschaftskrieg und es wird
immer erzählen dann bist du auch so
handeln ich kann nicht sagen ich bin im
Krieg und da mache ich ein bisschen
Sandkasten Spiele und jetzt was passiert
ist wir verlieren unser Wohlstand die
Amerikaner die ganz großen Gewinner die
haben in Amerika kostet
in die USA nach China und wenn die
Wirtschaft hier weg ist ist over aber
lassen Sie uns hier einmal noch mal ganz
plastisch werden was steht uns denn als
Wirtschaft bevor Massenarbeitslosigkeit
was sind die großen Maßnahmen
gute ist ja dass die wir sowieso eine
Schrumpfen der wärmebevölkerung haben
das heißt jetzt aber wird langsamer
zunehmen was passiert ist wir verlieren
Schlüsselindustrie es würde
Chemieindustrie Wissen Ludwigshafen
würde ich heute gebaut BASF geht nicht
weg nein aber derzeit hat Standorte in
USA in China sonst war auf der Welt die
erhöhen dort die Kapazitäten und wir
gehen hier runter zu fahren das ist ganz
natürliches Verhalten die Stahlindustrie
Aluminiumindustrie Aluminium kostet der
Strom in Deutschland ist höher die
Stromkosten für ein Kilo Aluminium ist
Deutschland ist höher als der
Weltmarktpreis das heißt wir machen
gerade ganz industrieplatz und dann
stellen wir uns sehen und sagen ja wir
müssen nur sicherstellen kann aber
Freunde wir sind gerade im vollen Tempo
der Industrialisierung und wir verlieren
diesen Krieg es nützen sie überhaupt
nichts wenn ein paar Jahren dann ähm die
Ukraine wieder frei ist alles drum und
dran alles ist frei wir haben den Krieg
aber verloren weil die Branchen die wir
verlieren die kommen nicht zurück und
vergessen wir nicht Welt beneidet
Deutschland darum dass wir immer noch
seinen hohen anteilindustrie haben
solide Zahlen ungefähr ein Viertel der
Deutschen Wertschöpfung erfindet in der
Industriestaat das sind gut bezahlte
Arbeitsplätze wissen Sie wenn die alle
wegfallen und wir uns gegenseitig in
Berlin mit der Cappuccinos verkaufen
das funktioniert nicht dann ist mit
Wohlstand oder ist alles Essig dann ist
er total statt Essig die rentenessig die
Krankenversicherung Essig in Deutschland
Champions muss man ganz klar sagen ganz
genau und den wird natürlich auch geht
es an den Kragen Industrie also Konzerne
Personenhaushalte der Mittelstand fällt
weg die die global aktiv sind die
Produktion waren das sind die nicht
aktiv sondern hier am Standort sind die
verlieren so massiv an
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit dass wir davon
ausgehen müssen dass es nicht mehr
existieren und ich bin ein ganz großer
Fender FDP aber ganz ehrlich ihr seid
mit in der Regierung und was der
Harbecke anziehen ich weiß nicht ob sie
jetzt die die Industrialisierung
beschleunigen wollen und CO2 wieder zu
zeigen ich weiß es nicht nur objektiv
gesehen ist es Quatsch was wir machen
und wir fahren vor die Wand und in der
Diskussion Atomkraftwerke verstehe ich
nicht ich würde mir auch eine Welt
wünschen wo ich nur mit Windrädern und
Sonne wir haben sie aber nicht noch mal
zur Erinnerung von den gesamten
Primärenergiebedarf Deutschlands kommen
16% aus neuerbaren Energien 16 %, die
Hälfte davon ist Biomasse also die
Verbrenner Holz auf Band das heißt 8 %,
kommt das Wind und Salat und wer ist
denn das Doppelte haben und übrigens
auch das ein letztes Wort gesagt na ja
er Habeck ist aber nicht an Schuld das
dass wenn die Situation sind das stimmt
weil er hat nicht die gasabhängigkeit
gefördert die wird gleich sagen na gut
die Energiewende hat das hingetrieben
aber lass mal den Kredit aber er war im
Amt am 24 februar und er hat 700 700
Zeit gehabt und davor zu bewahren das
hat er nicht getan und deshalb
kritisieren wir Fragen hier mal
Professor Schlögl auch als Osteuropa
Historiker konnte man das kommen sehen
können was jetzt passiert ist also war
es möglich diese Krisen dass das
passieren würde die Abhängigkeit zu
sehen als Politiker
ich glaube die Radikalität des Einbruchs
des zeitenbruchs das hatten kaum jemand
gesehen und selbst die ganz nah dran
waren an der Grenze an Aufmarsch an der
Front die Ukraine sie selber konnten
nicht glauben was am 24 Februar
frühmorgens passiert ist und deswegen
ist jetzt diese Rede dass man alles
schon hat gekommen sind und so weiter
das halte ich für eine Art von Bescheid
wisserei aber man hat bestimmte Dinge
doch gewusst und das erstaunlich ist
dass man nach der Krim Annexion das muss
man sich vorstellen nach der Annexion
hat man Dinge gemacht wie eben die
Verabschiedung der Pipeline wenn Nummer
zwei was ihr eigentlich ein
unglaublicher Vorgang gewesen ist mit
unglaublichen Erklärungen dass das
politisches Projekt sei das ist keine
geopolitische Bedeutung habe sondern
einen schlicht kommerzielles Projekt so
hat es Frau Merkel gesagt oder man hat
bis zuletzt hat man Gasspeicher und
Werke an die russischen Unternehmen
verkauft das ist alles unglaublich und
zeugt von einer großen
Ignoranz nicht wissen wollen und aber
die Frage ist wie sich diese ganze
Komplex einer gewissen Ahnungslosigkeit
eines nicht wahrhaben wollen wie sich
das aufgebaut hat und das ist nicht die
Sache einzelne Leute nur sondern ich
glaube da muss man wie das ein Kollege
formuliert hat den deutschen Russland
Komplex mal auseinander nehmen zu dem
man vielleicht extra noch diskutieren
könnte aber die Radikalität des
Einschnitts mit all diesen Konsequenzen
glaube ich waren unabsehbar also wenn
sie jetzt
in sehr katastropischen Szenarien vom
Untergang des deutschen Mittelstandes
sozusagen der
Exzellenz der deutschen Industriebahnen
das ist natürlich ich nehme das sehr
ernst und ich kann auch nicht teilen die
Auffassung dass man Kohlekraftwerke
still liegt in diesem Augenblick dass
man Atomkraftwerke nicht betreiben soll
ich teile diese Auffassung aber man muss
auch sagen dass die Regierung in sehr
kurzer Zeit den Ernst der Lage erkannt
hat und da muss ich habe den Schutz
nehmen er ist der Einzige der ganz klar
die Radikalität dieses Vorganges erkannt
hat was es heißt ein kontinentalkrieg
inmitten in Europa anzufangen das ist
der der ernste Sache und auf diesem
Hintergrund muss man die Entscheidung
sehen und dass man inzwischen eine
Diversifizierung der Energieversorgung
angefangen hat dass man den Grips ange
hat um zu überlegen wie man aus dieser
Abhängigkeit herauskommt das ist eine
eigentlich große Leistung auch in sieben
Monaten Regierungszeit also Sie haben
gerade Frau Merkel angesprochen die hat
sich heute geäußert das hat sehr lange
nicht mehr getan und da hören wir einmal
ganz kurz rein
und heute möchte ich angesichts der
Entwicklung der letzten Tage ergänzen
Worte ernst zu nehmen sie nicht von
vornherein damit abzutun sie sei nur ein
Bluff sondern sich ernsthaft mit ihnen
auseinanderzusetzen das ist beileibe
kein Zeichen von Schwäche oder
Beschwichtigung sondern ein
ausweispolitischer Klugheit einer
Klugheit die dazu beiträgt
Handlungsspielräume zu erhalten oder
mindestens so wichtig sogar neue zu
erarbeiten das waren die Worte heute von
Frau Merkel sie kennen Frau Merkel sie
war lange ihr militärpolitischer Berater
erfahrt wie schätzen Sie die Worte ein
die sie heute gesagt hat ja sie hat ja
mit gerade mit Blick auf diesen
vermeintlichen Bluff des
atomwaffeneinsatzes eben gesagt im
Klartext man muss das ernst nehmen und
sie hatte richtig gesagt von politischer
Klugheit gesprochen deswegen müssen wir
was den Ukraine Krieg anbelangt
rauskommen aus dieser reinen
Kriegsrhetorik auf das
eindimensionale des der Lieferung die
sind wichtig also klar brauchen die
Waffen aber wir brauchen auch politische
kluge politische Lösungen das ist die
Message so wie ich sie hier sehe und das
fehlt ja einfach komplett neu und das
ist im Grunde genommen der Punkt wo ich
auch der Meinung bin das müssen wir
ändern weil ich es ist richtig der
Ukraine zu helfen militärisch Sie in die
Lage zu versetzen das sind militärisch
nicht untergebuttert werden aber wir
haben nicht das Interesse der
strategische Interesse in einem dritten
Weltkrieg reingezogen zu werden und alle
30 Staaten der NATO haben das nicht weil
ich und das vermisse ich in der
deutschen Außenpolitik es ist zu stark
fokussiert auf Waffenlieferungen und zu
wenig oder gar nicht in Richtung auf
politisch diplomatische Initiativen und
das Putin nicht verhandlungsfähig ist
also das ist auch ein Ammenmärchen denn
wir haben parallel zu diesen
fürchterlichen Überfall und Krieg in der
Ukraine haben wir haben wir immerhin
dieses getreideabkommen ausgehandelt
bekommen und das ist doch tatsächlich
gelungen mit den Vereinten Nationen mit
Putin Erdogan ich muss auch sagen der
türkische Präsident der ist da flexibler
bei all den Nachteilen die die Türkei
hat die die Grünen wollen jetzt wieder
Sanktionen gegen die Türkei aussprechen
weil da natürlich menschenrechtliche
Technik bitte sind Rechtsstaatlichkeit
das ist alles in Ordnung aber
konstruktiver im Konfliktmanagement im
Krisenmanagement ist er bei all den
Defiziten wir bei uns ist absolut Zero
ich will ganz ehrlich
wir haben eben nicht vom Bluff Thema
gesprochen sondern von der
pipeline-frage und da gibt es eine klare
falsche Entscheidung und es wäre
großartig wenn die ehemalige Kanzlerin
ermutigt und
großzügig wäre einzugestehen dass sie
eine Fehlentscheidung nein das war keine
Fehlentscheidung sie haben im Grunde
genommen der Werte kommt eher
Wertekompass gegenüber Russland war
immer klar ich war ja auch beim Treffen
dabei mit Putin die hat eben mehrfach im
Arsch geblasen aber sie hat es in einer
das hat ja übrigens auch gesagt in einer
volle Art gemacht mir gefällt es auch
nicht dass Staatslenker man kann über
Putin sagen was man will kriminalisiert
werden ihre dargestellt werden krank
dargestellt werden wenn wir in diese
Rhetorik das ist permanent der Fall wenn
wir in dieser Rhetorik reingehen dann
kriegen wir am Ende keine Friedenslösung
mehr hin das ist doch das was sie meint
wir müssen doch da raus es gibt keine
militärische Lösung ich habe das so oft
gesagt man kann einen nuklear macht
militärisch nicht besiegen und Russland
ist die stärkste nuklearme der Welt
können sie hat auch das größte
militärpotential der Welt das heißt
nicht dass wir uns alles gefallen lassen
müssen also wir müssen die NATO stark
machen wir müssen im Appetit auf
imperiales mehr nehmen das ist schon
vollkommen richtig ne aber wir müssen
vernünftig mit diesem Konferenz dann
können sie aber auch nicht
wirtschaftlich besiegen aber auch dazu
sagen die Sanktionen dauern viel zu
lange und da ist aber wir besiegen uns
wirtschaftlich damit erstellt haben
wir haben erstmal so die Tatsache ist
durch unsere Sanktionen der mehr Geld
ein als davor weil nämlich die Preise
stark gestiegen sind also er hat weniger
verkauft kriegt mehr Menge
und ich möchte noch mal sagen wo ich mit
identifiziert nichts einer Meinung bin
ich bin mit einer Meinung dass der
Haarwerk sofort erkannt hat dass ein
Angriff richtig und er hat was getan
Diversifikation es war unstrittig ein
Fehler nur die auf die Pipeline zu
setzen und nicht zusätzlich noch einen
geht zu setzen und beide meines Arzt
immer noch ein großer Fehler auch unter
ökologischen Gesichtspunkt nicht das
ganze fördern was wir im Inland haben
das muss auch das ist so ein bisschen ja
sieht man anderes warum bin ich auch bei
uns verstehe ich nicht aber wie gesagt
das ist der Historie jetzt zu sagen hat
richtig erkannt ist ein anderes wir
befinden uns am Krieg wir befinden uns
ein Wirtschaftskrieg und dann genügt es
mit Verlaub gesagt es genügt nicht was
getan wurde ein Terminal zu bauen ja
dann fangen sie mal die katharis haben
die Katar ist ein Vertrag gemacht nein
weil die Kataris haben gesagt wir hätten
gern 20 Jahresvertrag warum haben sie
das gesagt weil die müssen ja auch
Kapazitäten aufbauen für Terminals und
so weiter und so fort dann wie gesagt
nein nein in drei Jahren dann wollen wir
nicht mehr also kommt das ja gar nicht
das kommt ja in dem Maße gar nicht und
deshalb hätte die anderen Maßnahmen auch
machen müssen es kann ich ihm
konzidieren das ist eine große großer
Schritt ist für ein zu sagen ich mag die
Atomkraftwerke die Kohlekraftwerke die
grüne Kohlekraftwerke kein Problem ist
die kohlepartei die haben die Kohle ja
über die Jahre wir sind ja deshalb so
viele Kohle weil wir die Kohle brauchen
das Backup da hätte mehr machen müssen
dass bei mir schon da ist sozusagen
diese Aktie erkennen der dramatische
Situation nicht in Einklang mit der
wirtschaftlichen wir der
Wirtschaftskrieg mit Russland wir
gewinnen denen nicht damit indem wir
kalt duschen und Waschlappen verwenden
den gewinnen wir nur indem wir den
rekosten runterbringen wenn sie wirklich
Russland Schwächen wollen müssen wir die
globalen Energiepreise runter kriegen
für Öl und vergaß ja das ist das
Russland die ist schlecht als es Öl 20
oder 30 Dollar war das heißt was müssen
wir machen wir müssen weltweit und in
die Ausbau von fossilen Energien mit der
investieren was mich getan haben wir
brauchen was sowieso und wir müssen in
Deutschland das auch tun wir können
nicht immer nur sagen macht ihr mal und
wir schauen wir müssen mitgehen nur so
gewinnt man gegen diesen Gegner er
vergeben wir nicht damit dass wir jetzt
sagen es gibt diese die
Industrialisierung und das dabei habe
ich dabei die Bundesregierung in den
sieben Monaten was getan aber sie hat
eben durch einen kleinen Hebel
gearbeitet und hat die großen Hebel sich
nicht getraut an